have you ever shown a friend a movie
only to hear them saying I don't get it
as the credits roll look everyone has
their own taste and that's great but
sometimes a confusion and disconnect
actually comes from the movie itself
being intentionally confusing
high-concept or just clumsily made let's
go over some of these films that make
people say huh and pat ourselves on the
back for the ones we know inside and out
spoilers ahead arrival this 2016 alien
invasion film offers a twist on the
popular genre by focusing the Plus on
efforts to communicate with the aliens
across a very tricky language barrier
it's a slower more low-key storyline we
spend most of the movie with Amy Adams
his world-renowned a linguist character
as she tries connecting with the
interstellar beings and begins to
understand their complex language as the
movie goes along we also get to see
flashes of her character in another life
caring for a daughter that we as the
audience know is doomed to die young
well it's natural to assume that what
we're seeing a flashbacks it turns out
we're witnessing a tragedy that actually
hasn't happened yet we learn at the
film's climax along with Adams character
that the aliens have their own more
circular way of perceiving time and the
bonds that they build if Adams ends up
allowing her to see into the future as
they do while it's among the 2016's most
critically acclaimed wide releases a
rival earned of B CinemaScore suggesting
a decent number of people walked away
somewhat confused with its complicated
somewhat challenging plot twists that's
understandable
but ultimately a shame this flick is
truly a cinematic joy and event on the
other side of the spectrum Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice this movie
isn't confusing because it's too smart
for the audience or anything like that
it's mostly that it just doesn't make
any sense from Wonder Woman's
motivations to the basic structure of
the plot Batman vs Superman is a movie
that barely hangs together
and only scrapes by thanks to sounds and
spectacle
the heavily criticized Martha moment
wasn't just a head-scratching failure
because it was weird even though it
totally was the real problem is that it
just wasn't enough to explain why Batman
would suddenly decide to not fulfill a
mission
he'd pursued obsessively to this point
this movie does a lot to convince us
that Batman believes with absolute
certainty that Superman is a danger to
the world so it really doesn't make
sense that having a mother with the same
name would be enough to deter Batman and
even have him describe himself as
Superman's friend just a few scenes
later a friendly shot I figured the Cape
this coupled with the movie's
unexplained a dream sequences and Jesse
Eisenberg's nutso version of Lex Luthor
makes the film feel fundamentally
illogical incomplete and frustrating
lots of longtime fans of these
characters were pretty upset with how
the movie handled the source material
and the Batman vs Superman was someone's
introduction to the DC Universe they
probably left the theater wondering what
the hell they just got themselves into
only God forgives Nikolas wounding rafin
and ryan gosling have followed up their
dreamy and fantastic film drive with a
hard left turn into the abstract with
2013's only God forgives taking the
action to Thailand Gosling stars as
essentially a way less interesting non
driving version of his character from
Drive he spends a big chunk of the movie
wandering through the dreamy Bangkok
cityscape leaving audiences to wonder
what the hell is going on if that wasn't
weird enough putting enough were also
treated to surreal karaoke sequences
from a character called both lieutenant
Chiang and the Angel of Death and
described by the director as quote a
mythological creature that has a
mysterious past but cannot relate to
reality because he's heightened and his
pure fetish okay the entire movie is
kinda like that and it's not hard to
imagine that some folks left the theater
feeling worried that they weren't smart
enough to understand it well he has some
good news there's not actually much
going on in this overblown film for
anyone who left a movie feeling confused
there in sweater you were totally
justified none of this makes any sense
Prometheus fans and critics alike have
talked about this movie's puzzling
failures quite a bit but there are
plenty of good reasons to do so
especially when you consider just how
much potential Prometheus had the film
is an ambiguous prequel in the alien
film franchise but it unfortunately
confused audiences with everything from
its characters
basic motivations - it's strange
conclusion I think there might be some
confusion about our relationship the
truth is that Prometheus almost works
but it falls short as it spends a lot of
time hinting at the plot and story while
failing to actually deliver the
necessary parts that make an audience
care even longtime fans were unable to
connect to anything happening in front
of them drawing Prometheus it was so
weird and fundamentally unsatisfying
that is no surprise the franchise is
eager to get some distance from this one
prometheus 2 has been renamed alien
covenant and fans hopes are high that it
can bring the franchise back to form the
butterfly effect serious actor Ashton
Kutcher's the butterfly effects is one
of the dumbest movies ever to remain
essentially watchable while being
completely illogical at the same time
while you might think the movie makes
sense if you take even a second to
really think about the plot it totally
falls apart catches protagonist as
blessed or perhaps cursed with the
ability to use old personal tokens to
phase back through time to memorable
moments in his life and so he spends the
bulk of the movie trying to fix his
mistakes
usually only to emerge in situations
that are even worse the premise and
baseline rule of the movie that the
slightest change can alter the course of
your life entirely gets thrown out of
the window time and time again whenever
the script deems it necessary in one
scene as Kutcher tries to defend himself
inside a violent prison he goes back in
time to stop his hands frightening the
other inmates with his sudden new wounds
but if going back in time to change the
slightest thing changes everything then
why is could chest still in jail why did
the wounds appear as if by magic instead
of appearing scarred over after what
should have been an entire life of
having them is it really worth it to try
and figure out this movie's logic well
know so if you don't get this one don't
worry too much no one really does it's a
great example of a pretty good idea that
ultimately was poorly executed and left
much to be desired ah well thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
you